- This button nose specifically,
would have been very
useful to me as a child.
(squeaking)
(energetic upbeat music)
- [Kendall] I grew up super Christian.
- [Abigail] I lived in
the middle of nowhere.
- [Vivian] On a farm raising cattle.
- [Tuisdi] Smaller city in Texas.
- We had to go to church every single
Sunday, Monday and Wednesday.
- Where I'm at, if you didn't go to church
there was something wrong with you.
- We couldn't listen to any rap music,
couldn't watch music videos.
We couldn't do anything that
people my age wanted to do.
- We were required to have sex ed.,
but it didn't have to
be medically acurate,
and it was abstinence only.
We kind of, briefly
learned what periods were.
- But when it came to how to do things
and what things were
meant for what places,
that didn't really exist.
- My understanding of it was that sex
was for married people to make babies.
(energetic upbeat music)
After I had seen, Star Wars: Episode VI.
- I was reading a, Harry
Styles fan fiction.
- And I realized that
when I saw Leah in her slave costume,
I was having special feelings.
- I was um, up in my room
and a Lil' Kim video was
on, she was twearkin'.
Oh my God, when I was younger!
- And it ended up with
me going to my room,
and having some fun with
some stuffed animals.
- That was the first time
that I had felt like,
hot and bothered really and I had like,
weird feelings down
there, and I didn't know
how to deal with it or what to do.
- So I'm goin' at it, I'm goin' at it
and as soon as I get finished
my mom busts in my room.
I'm like, oh my...
I didn't know what to do,
and then she noticed that the covers
were all the way up to my,
all she could see is my face.
She rips the covers off of me.
It looked like I had a baseball bat
in my pants like, I'm
still there, you know.
Next thing I know, we're in the car
on the way to the preacher's house.
- So I would go to the winter bucket
where we kept all of our scarves,
and I would tie them around myself
to sort of look like slave Leah.
- We go over there, the pastor,
we're holding hands, me, him, and my mom.
They make me bow my head.
The pastor's like, God I just want you
to break this demon
that Kendall has in him.
We don't know where it came from.
We know he wasn't raised like this
and his family's disappointed
in him and I am too,
but we know that you have the power.
I'm just sittin' there like, oh my God.
I cannot believe this is happening.
- Pretty much everything I learned
about sex was via the internet.
- I started reading magazines.
Oh, I remember just being
obsessed with Cosmo,
because of the fact that
it gave me more information
than I was getting, but you know,
I don't need 50 million tips on
how to tickle his pickle or whatever.
- I think it's very important
to have sex ed. in schools.
- When I was in high school, I think
we had three teen pregnancies.
- You know, I had a lot of friends
that got talked into things or were drunk
when it happened, and didn't realize
until many years later
that they hadn't consented.
Like, it wasn't sex.
- I absolutely think that people
can be sexual and also be religious.
- There's so many
contradictions in the Bible,
and as an adult I can't ignore
those contradictions you know,
but at the same time I
know that there is a god.
I'm still, I'm still Christian.
- If you do believe in that higher power,
you're created to be the person
who you are meant to be, no
matter what that entails.
You are who you are,
and you are entitled to
that self-love and God is
gonna love you no matter what.
- And then she's on top of the...
Oh my goodness.
This scene right here made
me wanna lose my virginity.
This scene right here.
Too hot for TV,
oh my God.
That's how you know you wasn't
supposed to be watchin' it.